[Música]
en la ciudad ucraniana de heart quien
grupos de desactivación de explosivos se
juegan la vida recogiendo municiones de
bombas de racimo y un equipo de france
24 los acompañó en sus labores
ucrania vivió a una jornada cargada de
simbolismos y diplomacia además de la
reunión de los líderes del g-7 en la que
se resolvió abandonar el petróleo ruso
los músicos de la banda u2 ofrecieron un
breve concierto en el metro de tierra
y rusia conmemora este 9 de mayo el
aniversario número 77 de la victoria
soviética sobre la alemania nazi una
celebración que este año se ve empañada
por la invasión a ucrania
hola bienvenidos a las noticias de
france 24 en español gracias por seguir
acompañándonos santiago arístide
comenzamos esta emisión con información
sobre la guerra en ucrania y es que las
bombas de racimo son especialmente
mortíferas cuando son utilizadas contra
la población civil y en jarquín y
unidades especializadas en desactivación
de explosivos lidian con ellas a diario
nuestras enviadas especiales acompañaron
a esta unidad de élite en el frente de
jarque
es el momento en el que la brigada de
explosivos retira un cohetes smerch en
la localidad debes ludoteca bombardeada
en los últimos días
el misil de la era soviética mantiene
solo su carcasa la munición impactó en
el bosque cercano
antes de mover el proyectil tienen que
asegurar y medir cada paso pues podría
tener munición en su interior un mínimo
error sería fatal
arthur jefe del grupo lo sabe bien dos
son stocks o proceso trigo en su fe pero
posible sólo trabajan con la luz del día
acuden a las llamadas de los vecinos y
de las autoridades locales para retirar
restos de municiones peligrosas tam ya
estaba escondida en su casa cuando un
estruendo la puso en alerta
eran las 10 de la mañana no lo vimos lo
escuchamos al principio pensamos que
eran los perros pero luego nos dimos
cuenta de que no cuando vuelan los
misiles los perros empiezan a ladrar
este grupo especial se juega la vida ya
lo ven recogiendo misiles trozos de
misiles bombas minas y también sus
municiones de bombas de racimo que han
caído aquí en jarquín olec tiene sólo 24
años y lleva desde los 20 trabajando en
esto pero con la guerra cada día es
distinto
lo que más nos encontramos son
fragmentos de misiles smerch o
normalmente la parte trasera del misil o
el tubo pero cada vez más encontramos
dentro de estos misiles munición de
racimo varias organizaciones
internacionales han denunciado el uso de
bombas de dispersión en ucrania o le
confirma que ha retirado este tipo de
arma que es especialmente mortífera
contra objetivos civiles por el número
de pequeñas municiones que se esparcen y
estallan
si encontramos su munición de racimo no
hemos desactivado por el momento minas
antipersona porque están en la línea de
fuego ahora pero sí que hemos
recolectado minas antitanque cuando las
encontramos acordonamos la zona
evacuamos a quienes estén allí
desactivamos la munición y nos
deshacemos de ella
estos son los misiles que recolectaron
desde que empezó la guerra probablemente
servirán para futuras investigaciones
entre los restos hay bombas letales
utilizadas contra la población civil en
ucrania
y este domingo ucrania fue escenario de
visitas simbólicas desde los músicos de
youtube hasta la primera dama
estadounidense jill biden se hicieron
presentes para apoyar al país
de refugio contra los bombardeos a salón
de conciertos el metro de kiev fue el
escenario de un homenaje al ritmo de la
banda irlandesa u2 la voz de uno
acompañada de la guitarra de diez se
unieron en un pedido de paz para el
pueblo ucraniano
su presidente lidera el mundo en la
causa de la libertad en este momento
el pueblo de ucrania no solo está
luchando por su propia libertad
está luchando por todos los que amamos
la libertad
un concierto improvisado lleno de
simbolismo
los músicos estuvieron acompañados de
tar hasta paul ya líder de una banda
ucraniana juntos entonaron la canción
stand by me
tras el espectáculo vuelve la guerra
joe biden boris johnson recep erdogán
olaf scholz emanuel macrón úrsula von
der leyen les pido que ayuden a nuestro
presidente y nuestra diplomacia para
sacar a los soldados ucranianos de
mariupol as hostal donde los rusos están
organizando literalmente un infierno
mientras que cantamos esta canción en la
frontera oeste del país otro escenario
poco habitual el día de la madre unió la
primera dama de eeuu jill biden a su
homóloga ucraniana olena zelenka en un
cruce fronterizo a grecia
[Música]
pensé que era importante mostrarle al
pueblo ucraniano que esta guerra tiene
que terminar y
que esta guerra ha sido brutal y que el
pueblo de eeuu está con el pueblo de
ucrania
el primer ministro canadiense josh
instruido por su parte rompió con la
diplomacia informal del día y anunció
mayor asistencia militar y equipos para
las fuerzas ucranianas
y este 9 de mayo rusia conmemora el
aniversario número 77 de la victoria
soviética sobre la alemania nazi momento
decisivo en el fin de la segunda guerra
mundial y este año por supuesto la
celebración está empañada por la
invasión a ucrania
es un día que marcó la historia de la
unión soviética y que ahora rusia
conmemora el 9 de mayo de 1945 los rusos
pusieron punto final a su ofensiva
contra berlín y las tropas de la
alemania nazi terminando con la segunda
guerra mundial un hito histórico mundial
que se consagró con un desfile militar
en junio de
1945 en
1965 el líder leonid bréznev tomó la
celebración y la declaró fiesta nacional
la conmemoración se retomó cada diez
años hasta 1995 luego cada 5 y desde
2008 se celebra anualmente como la gran
fiesta nacional y despliegue de poderío
militar como lo destacó el presidente
vladimir putin tan sólo dos días después
de asumir el cargo en el 2000
date
y más nuestro pueblo dio todo lo que
tenía por la victoria recordamos no sólo
los logros de nuestros soldados sino
también el honor y la gloria de los que
trabajaron heroica mente en el frente
interno nos inclinamos ante todos
ahora 77 años después del día de la
victoria en una guerra en la que los
rusos y ucranianos combatieron juntos
bajo la bandera soviética los nietos de
esos soldados ahora luchan unos contra
otros tras la invasión rusa a ucrania
pero no sólo la guerra de hoy marca una
brecha en las celebraciones
históricamente ha habido diferencias
profundas en la narrativa con la que se
conmemora la victoria en moscú casi
nunca se habla del pacto
molotov-ribbentrop de no agresión entre
la alemania nazi y la unión soviética
vigente de 1939 a 1941 conocido también
como el pacto hitler stalin tampoco
destaca en la narrativa heroica el costo
de millones de vidas que tuvo la
victoria a diferencia de occidente
lucia destaca que si en la invasión nazi
a la urss y la apertura del frente
oriental el curso de la guerra para los
aliados podría haber sido muy distinto a
diez años la unión soviética se llevó la
peor parte del ataque de los fascistas
enviaron tres cuartas partes de sus
tropas al frente oriental y más allá de
estas diferencias
y ha sido una celebración compartida
pero este año será el primero en que
rusia no reciba a dirigentes extranjeros
en la celebración empañada por la guerra
en ucrania
y el juicio en el que el actor johnny
depp acusa de difamación a su ex esposa
ámbar heart ha derivado en una enorme y
mediatización y en todo tipo de
reacciones en las redes sociales y a
través de ellas se han creado contenidos
que afectan la percepción de este
litigio son apuestos ricos y famosos y
eso parece encantar al mundo los
espectadores fascinados siguen el juicio
transmitido por televisión y por
plataformas como youtube en el que depp
acusa a su ex esposa de difamación por
un artículo publicado en the washington
post en 2018 en el que asegura haber
sufrido de abuso doméstico todo lo que
se dice se ha convertido en una
avalancha de contenidos en redes
sociales que las redes sociales como
todos los mensajes de los medios de
comunicación son recortes de lo que
ocurre lo estamos viviendo como una
especie de serie de netflix como una
especie de
película en etapas este ha sido tan
mediatizado que un canal como el down
crime que hace una transmisión en vivo
tiene al menos 9 millones de
espectadores conectados todos los días o
court tv que ha cuadruplicado su
audiencia según asegura el diario
independent hay un interés y una
relevancia pero el peligro el peligro de
este interés es la trivialización y la
banalización por eso vemos
inmediatamente después de cada
testimonio clips vídeos twitter se llena
de tendencias sobre el juicio algunas de
carácter violento tick tock se desborda
de toda clase de vídeos en los que se
analiza expone e incluso ridiculizar a
ambos actores la cantidad de información
que tenemos información
descontextualizada información
fragmentaria lo que va haciendo es
generar una tendencia respecto de la
creación de opiniones
incluso para quienes están viendo el
juicio los vídeos de recortes sobre el
mismo juicio
construyen una forma de leer lo que pasa
distinta como una película con un guión
truncado el rol que no le fue asignado a
haití y ha de seguir acondicionando su
popularidad
regresamos en breve con muchas más
noticias sigan en france 24
[Música]